er ging weil das sind abgeordneten
kollegen die aus dem bundestag die sich
da bereichert haben sollen mit masken
deals teilweise summen bis zu 650.000
euro was fällt ihnen dazu ein
also das muss natürlich auch geklärt
werden bei im nüßlein ermittelt die
staatsanwaltschaft da sind viele offene
fragen aber auch der kollege der fall
jetzt heute bekannt geworden ist auf
mehrere hunderttausend euro und ich muss
ganz klar sagen das ist ein schäbiges
verhalten das ist höchst unanständig wir
haben als politikerinnen und politiker
gerade die aufgabe das land und die
menschen durch eine schwere pandemie
durchzubringen und da erwarten alle dass
wir täglich hart dafür arbeiten und wenn
jetzt in einer solchen phase
politikerinnen und politiker sich
persönlich bereichern
dann ist das schädlich das ist
unanständig und das schadet der politik
insgesamt
und da kann man jetzt nur erwarten dass
die unionsfraktion schnell an dass er
konsequent gehandelt wird und ich hoffe
dass nicht noch weitere fälle bekannt
werden
wünschenswert die beiden abgeordneten
werfen ein schlechtes licht auf sich
selbst und auf den kompletten bundestag
was erwarten sie denn konkret für
konsequenzen eckball
jetzt gehört das in müssen sich
zurückzieht das ist erstmal das ist
erstmal richtig aber es muss doch
aufgeklärt werden wie das überhaupt dazu
kommen konnte was da passiert ist also
das heißt auch auf einem transparent in
dem die abgeordnete handeln der mit
scotty woche ja uns geeinigt in der
position auf ein lobbyregister und jetzt
muss man prüfen ob man die
geschäftsordnung des bundestages noch
weiter überarbeiten muss also wie ist
das mit transparenz aber ich sage ihnen
auch ganz klar kennen viele abgeordnete
das sind alles ehrenwerte menschen die
sich einsetzen gerade für ihren
wahlkreis für dieses land arbeiten
wahnsinnig vielen ich merke dass bei mir
im eigenen bei pressestellen sich so
viele leute bei mir wie noch nie die
hilfe brauchen die unterstützung
brauchen
aber wie kann man denn da auf die idee
kommen dass man sich persönlich
bereichert also es ist wirklich
unanständig das macht mich fassungslos
und das zeigt ja auch dass dabei einige
abgeordnete nicht was auf eine schiefe
bahn gekommen ist und nur das schadet
der politik insgesamt
und ich frage mich auch was
wahrscheinlicher brinkhaus dazu was sagt
laschet dazu ich höre die alle nicht und
vielleicht sollten dann auch die
führende unionspolitiker sich mal äußern
zu müssen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren